please be standing for the chairman of
Senate District Council
thank you please be seated
good evening members and officers of the
council members of the press in public I
welcome you to this council meeting
Thursday 6th of December 2018
housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs however through these
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer please do not use
the lifts please assemble in holy square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured I urge
anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening thank you any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
can I ask everyone present to please
ensure that their mobile phones are turn
to silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls in the
chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress
general item 1 is apologies for absence
I've received apologies from absence
from councillors Bainbridge Curran Dixon
Evans and messenger are there any other
apologies for absence councillor fear
bars councillors Wells and Connor
thank you done that thank you
soya cows the piper I'll move my
position I couldn't see your arm there
for a minute
Thank You Jett castor John Dennis
counselor Trevor shock counselor Roy
Potts and count for the Bertie Braidwood
thank you thank you do I assume they
didn't want my mid spires and drinks
afterwards they said I could have them
germinated a tender item two minutes of
previous meeting held on the 11th and
15th October I move that the minutes of
the meetings of the council held on the
11th and 15th of October 2018 the
approved and signed as a correct record
with the vice chairman please second a
second that chair thank you do members
agree thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 6th of
November 2018 I move that the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting of the council
held on the 6th of November 2018 be
approved and signed as a correct record
once a game with the vice chairman
please second second Chet do members
agree thank you Jen right on for
announcements members can we take a
moment to acknowledge the excellent
conduct of one of our civil enforcement
officers for his professional response
to a very challenging situation
Dean remained calm and professional
while under pressure and tonight
is recognized for his excellent conduct
and our thanks go to Dean who this
evening is being presented with an
acknowledging excellent certificate in
appreciation for his response so
I'm standing you don't need to stain
Thank You members another announcement I
am sure members will join me in
congratulating Tom Davis our empty homes
officer who has won the rising star
award at this year's empty homes Awards
this is a national award that recognizes
new empty homes practitioners who have
made significant contributions over a
short period of time once again I'd like
you to give your appreciation and our
thanks go to Tom thank you one more
announcement tonight I'd like to take
this opportunity to invite all fanuc
district councillors for a Christmas
drink and mince pies in the business
suite on the first floor after this
meeting I very much hope that you will
be able to adjoin attend and join me in
a pre festivity drink and mince pie I
can assure you that all of them inspires
of well within their eat by date so no
problems in that direction agenda item 5
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest that gender
item six petitions to petitions have
been received in accordance with council
procedure rule number 12
gender items 6a is a petition regarding
the Margate Museum and the mayor's
parlor a petition containing 94 valid
signatures has been received by the
council I am pleased to welcome mr.
Smith Stewart to the meeting could you
please make your way to the top table
Thank You mr. Smith Stewart's you now
have three minutes to speak
Oh speak as fast as a kindness
attainment good evening everybody I'm
sure your members probably know me for a
number of years working hard and Margay
anyway and the petition stays asking the
council to retake they're not to sale
the museum and attend whole I think the
tone hole basically the Homa thorniest
one bid the other and I don't know what
the position is at the moment but
perhaps if somebody could give me an
idea what's going on and normally good
is speaking about a little bit painful
tonight not you buddy
anyway again I do the counts all of you
decide this this you at home whoever
comes me and next time in my okay and of
course market is up and coming or visit
us there were certain numbers are going
up the volunteers are doing a fantastic
job who perhaps money could be found in
other ways thank you thank you mr. Smith
Stuart I'm sure we all agree with the
contents of your speech can I confirm
that in accordance with the council
petitions scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet without debate for a
report to the council within the next
three ordinary meetings thank you
a general item 6b is a petition
regarding the port of Ramsgate a
petition containing 1119 valid
signatures and an e petition containing
a hundred and fifty-four valid
signatures has been received by the
council I am pleased to welcome mr.
Coons to the meeting could you please
make your way to the top table
mr. Coombes as your mr. Coombes as your
petition contained one over 1,000
signatures you have five minutes to
speak Merry Christmas
the pentose season is upon us and it's
comedy chair my name is Steve Coombs and
I'm chair of the Ramsgate Action Group
now I'm sure many of you might be
surprised to see me speaking here
tonight as TVC says I'm vexatious and
unreasonable complainants and will just
keep to the point and I'm mr. Koontz I'm
about to mr. chair so let's assume for
the sake of arguments that I really am
the harassing stalking death threatener
of their imagination now ask yourself
mr. Coombes we're drifting can you just
so sent the bow basis of the petition
please we don't want any comments
regarding I think is gone that's not a
comment for me that's the comments from
the council sorry right now
ask yourself one very simple question
who do you trust more to give you
accurate information about the port's me
or TDC when you want to know where the
Seabourn Freight can pass due diligence
and compliance who'd you listen to me or
TDC are we're talking about the basis of
the petition the basis of the petition
this is all this all this petition is we
have no confidence in the council's
operation of the port if I cannot make
statements to explain why we have no
confidence in the council's Operations
report I don't think you're allowing me
to speak to the through the prayer of
the petition I will allow you to speak
as long as we keep it factual and we
don't drift off too far thank you who
told you
Seabourn freights were capitalized at 66
pounds who told you they had no
employees no investors no credible
business plan and no ships
rag did a brexit Brazilians who gave you
a detailed expert an authoritative
analysis with diagrams and charts as to
why 24 sailings a day could never work
even with a 35 million pound dredge we
did and it came from X ferry captains
and freight logistics experts so you
don't have to I don't have to persuade
you you don't have any confidence in the
council's operations to the port's you
already know that the question is what
do you intend to do about it now the
problem is as soon as I finish speaking
the petition will be remitted to
cabinets and maybe in three or four
meetings time it will come back to you
if you put up with that you will commit
the port to another six months of losses
sorry
booked losses about a million quid
following on from the two million pounds
that has been lost since negotiations
began with Seabourn Freight last
November which followed on from the two
million pound per year of booked losses
whilst discussions were held with a host
of other ferry companies that never
materialized five years of this nonsense
and an accumulated deficit of over 21
million pounds in the meantime TDC is
cutting services by over 1 million
pounds a year so rag believes that you
as councillors have a duty to your
voters to put a stop to this to insist
on an open transparent rational and
independent review of the port where all
the options are put on the table and
where the advantages and disadvantages
are laid out in plain English
in clear numbers for all to see and I
expect right I absolutely hate some of
those options but if you've got a case
you can make it now add a stretch the
mechanism for this independent review
could be the new port working party but
not if it's just serviced by the CMT but
maybe if it was able to receive outside
submissions if it had access to Frank
experts and authoritative independent
opinion and advice it might just be fit
for purpose so ladies and gentlemen of
the council on behalf of every council
taxpayer in the district I commend to
you this prayer thank you thank you mr.
combs well done well rehearsed
I think you had another six seconds
there but thank you very much as the
petition relates to an issue for which
the executive cabinet has responsibility
it will be referred to by counsel to
cabinet Thank You councillor Johnson
this petition I think has more than a
thousand signatures at one point two if
a petition contains more than a thousand
signatures council can debate the
petition unless it falls into a category
exception as detailed paragraph a and B
of one point six of the scheme in this
case paragraph B would be appropriate
namely so it goes on about the thousand
signatures so I'm feeling that we should
be allowed to debate this and I actually
think that's a very good recommendation
of having an independent body look at
the issue because maybe some of us are
too close to it thank you
Thank You councillor Johnson you're
absolutely right
Kelso pipe and then counts the Campbell
please Thank You mr. chairman I was just
going to ask for some clarity please on
the paragraph 3.1 on page 19 it says
under paragraph 1.6 brackets B of the
councillors petition scheme if the
petition with a thousand almost
as relates to an issue for which the
executive brackets cabinet has
responsibility it may following
presentation be referred to Council by
counsel to cabinet without debate could
you please clarify it may or it will
thank you Jeff the answer is it may and
therefore counsel could debate it
instead if it wishes counsel Campbell
point made chair thank you
does counsel wish to debate counsel
Pipal Thank You chair it was just a
quick one there has been some difficulty
it's been acknowledged in various
members receiving communications from
mr. Coombes given that he has been given
permission to address this council this
evening can we be assured that all other
means of contact between him and elected
members will be reopened on a permanent
basis
thank you check counselor Johnson thank
you and chairman I did actually try to
move that we do debate at this evening
and not refer it straight to cabinet
it's too important an issue not to be
discussed in open forum and I personally
my personal I haven't discussed it with
the group here but I personally feel
that an independent body looking at or
everything to do with the port would be
a good idea in a way forward and maybe
even this could be something decided by
Cabinet later but an independent group
from another Council to look at this
because the rumors and the conversations
that are outside this council are again
dragging us into even more discredit
outside and I think it's important that
a totally independent group look at this
not officers from here not members from
here but somebody independent of us from
another council that's what I'd like to
move Thank You counsel Campbell do you
want to come back I was going to second
the fact that we debated this evening
yes
so if that was a proposal from Hansel
Johnson that we debate this particular
issue this evening then I actually
second that proposal thank you
that's quite all right counts a camel
I will debate it counts of hayford yeah
Thank You German um well I don't really
want to get into too much comment about
mr. Coombes and the way he's behaved
over recent times I think that most
people have seen some of the policies
put up and I think a lot of them are
fairly despicable and I think that's a
bit unfortunate there's a couple of
points I'd like to make go in first it's
absolutely right that I have proposed
and in from the proposed members of a
Portland Harbor working party I have
chosen councillors who both live in
Ramsgate and represent Ramsgate boards
democratically elected people that I
think fit to actually be on that
committee and its first meeting I don't
know if the dates been fixed I mean they
were looking for to get Diaries together
and the first duty of that committee
will be to determine its terms of
reference and there we can consider all
sorts of things I would just a little
bit like to question what the mandate
that mr. Coombes has he made no mention
of the petition really talked about that
rag oh I'm not sure how many members
Raiders got but but the petition had
1273 signatures on it now if we were to
be charitable and assumed that all of
those came from Ramsgate that represents
three percent of the population of
Ramsgate which I don't think he's much
of a mandate a very cursory glance that
the petitioner today showed me that a
significant number very significant
number of the signatures were people not
living in Ramsgate let's be charitable
game and assume that they live in
planets that means the mandate is less
than one percent of the residents planet
but what did interest me was the fact
that it does appear that there is
concern about the running of our poll in
Dover nightstand Hearn by deal can't
vary which double Tunbridge Dartford
hemel hempstead the very worried about
that hemel hempstead Reigate Woodford
green Horsham it's which killing them
trigger Sutton Coldfield Newport and
Brixton so in deference to those people
we will actually hold their committee
meetings and we will consider the future
of the poll thank you thank you
Thank You Council papered counts the
constant I thank you very much chair
hoping you won't cut me off too soon
tonight and God just say um I think it's
unfortunate when we when we move to a
position in this chamber where we talk
about members of the public that spend
their time bringing matters to our
attention and regardless counts the
Beauford of your subjective analysis of
Steve Coombs and rags petition I think
it's quite wrong to say some of the
things that you've said actually because
the points that have been raised by
Steve Coombs tonight and by rag I'm a
loretta Denton in Ramsgate have been for
a number of years I can tell you from
living there and from being the County
Council there the County Council there
that these issues are very live actually
we have an asset that is losing money we
have an asset that people can see isn't
doing what it should be doing we have an
asset that isn't making any money and we
have an asset that is losing money and
people are frankly scratching their
heads and wondering what the heck their
local council and counselors are up to
so I think we do need to have an urgent
look at the port this is been going on
for so long I think we are unforgive the
pond I think we're all out of our depth
and I think we do need an independent
set of eyes independent bodies looking
at this and council Bay furred please
don't kick this down the road this has
been going on for too long
and the reason I asked you not to kick
this down the road and kick it into the
long grass and obscure it for a number
of months for coming forward is because
the needs in our community are
skyrocketing and it's our job I say this
all the time in this chamber it's our
job as local councillors to attempt to
meet the needs of our residents and
that's what we should be doing so I
proposed in actually that this panel is
comprised of it
stern experts are we giving some proper
independent robust advice Thank You
Council on Stein Kelsey Campbell did I
see your hand up quickly and then I just
to inform those gathered here and the
petitioner that counselor Beaufort is
quite right there has been a meeting
date set for the Working Group it is the
12th of this month and I'm on it it will
not be kicked into the long grass I
think counselor by furred will know and
understand that when he asked me to join
this group that I was not going to
accede to any kicking in the long grass
we will form our terms of reference I do
believe that external experts may have a
place to play in this particular working
group but we will on the 12th determine
that from the number of people who have
been invited action now eventually has
been taken and is being taken I think
this is in part in almost totally in
part for the residents of Maiwald
including reg actually causing let's say
this issue to rise above the waters and
I will report back it's not a secret
working party the results of it will not
be a secret working party and I will
keep members informed as to the outcome
of the working party Thank You chair I
think the answer is exercising their
enthusiasm council Byford yeah Thank You
chairman responding to accounts of
Constantine I seriously resent the
remarks that you made about me the chief
executive will be able to confirm that
the Friday after I became leader of this
council which I remember because it was
the first day of the beast for the east
so I skated down the road to get into
this council and actually true things
that made the efforts come into well a
discussion about the things that were on
my list of priorities number one was the
local plan number two I think she can
confirm was the port and I made it
absolutely clear that the situation that
pertained to the port could not go off
and that's I've said that right the
beginning and it really does get my goat
that I'm being pilloried particularly by
mr. Coombes all the time for doing
nothing about it that's not true
but things do take a certain amount of
time there's a lot of stuff going on in
the background here the committee will
be brought up to speed on that
so please counter constant don't accuse
me of kicking the can down the road
never have done never will do Thank You
councillor Johnson thank you very much
chairman I'm the fortunate person in
2008 just sit on a working party very
similar to what has been described by
councillor Campbell it was chaired by
councillor Beaufort I was busy I was
going to work and actually had quite a
serious illness that year but I got
taxis over to Ramsgate for those
meetings and talk about kicking into the
long grass we never achieved anything I
read everything as I always do about
municipal reports I learnt everything
that I needed to know and we never had a
final outcome we had officers coming and
then it just suddenly died a death
what mortifies me having been a leader
in here in 2014-2015 is that there may
have been issues that I knew nothing
about as a leader and we have to be
honest with each other
if I wasn't given all the information as
a leader and I was pretty good about
asking questions I want someone to find
out what happened in my time that I
wasn't told about and I won't shy away
from it and I don't think any leader
should I think it's fine if you've set
up a working party which you did and
that's good but I've been on one that
was kicked into the long grass 10 years
ago please don't do it again please look
to an independent expert body to do this
because otherwise we're all wasting our
time and my reputation and every leaders
reputation before depends on us getting
this right and the officers who were
supposed to give us all her advice
weren't telling me about 2 million a
year losses the other point that needs
to be made is that people who signed
this petition from other parts of the
country by its very definition at
support it's a marina there are people
from outside the area who use it
they're probably signing petitions I had
this from a tourism point of view are we
were accused to false signatures the
people who were in hotels signing saying
through lack of lavatories many years
ago and they weren't false signatures
there were signatures of people who saw
the problems we had please look at this
if we can go back to cabinet to
do it properly and get another counsel
to help us then we can all say we did
our best no problem with a working party
on other basics but I wasn't told
everything when I was the leader and I
will admit to that because I did my best
to find the truth every time but I
didn't always get the full facts thank
you thank you I've got Council recessed
key and councillor Martin did you want
to respond quickly but counsel David a
couple of points there first of all I
didn't suggest though a bogus signatures
at all well I suggested were they were
from strange parts of the country and
the other thing I could have said was
that in my experience petitions can be
an unreliable bill whether Republic
opinion there was some years ago a major
major issue in my wall absolutely
divided the world and it was a
black-and-white issue
it was there totally for it totally
against it each side got a petition
quite successful petitions when I
returned it turned out that quite a
significant proportion of people had
signed both petitions now people do sign
petitions for all sorts of reasons
sometimes because they're very very
committed to the cause sometimes because
it's the quickest way to get rid of
somebody somebody sometimes because I
haven't been told quite what it's about
and haven't read the bid at the top so
it is a bit unreliable I do think where
that's concerned did grand back to the
and I'm suggesting they're bogus people
I'm just suggesting that they might not
have been particularly relevant to the
issue that we're talking about here the
other thing is I remembered working
parties back in those days I also
remember that we had some absolutely
interminable torturous meetings over at
the port office where we got mired in
ways and setting up harbor boards and
now they were going to be set up and
whatever and we couldn't reach any
decision basically the meetings were
going nowhere which is why they didn't
continue thank you
Thank You councillor council recess key
Thank You chairman just a quick thing I
welcome the fact that the council seemed
to agree that we should bait this issue
but whether tonight would be the right
time I'm not so sure I feel that as a
conscientious councillor I would need a
bit more time to be able to gather the
information from various sources and
places to be
come to this council and actually debate
it properly and therefore would like to
move that we don't actually debate it
tonight but we debate do set a time and
date to debated thank you I was under
the impression we were debating a Cloud
Servers esky but we're looking I think
the proposal has already been discussed
councillor Martin thank you very much
chair there is a word that I would like
to bring into this chamber because it's
a word which I think we all need to
acknowledge and perhaps own and that is
regeneration it is a word that was used
a lot nearly four years ago by various
candidates for Parliament and it
certainly is a word which has been
carried forward within the regeneration
alliance the port in harbor for me very
much come within that concept that we
need a plan we need a vision we need
imagination which is economically viable
and which can be repeated in other
coastal areas because this is not just
an issue for us it is also a national
issue I also want to record my
appreciation to mr. Coombes
for his excellent research we should be
very welcoming to a member of our
community who is able and capable of
doing that level of research and it's
not something that I take for granted
and I really want to acknowledge that
and to just thank him what do we do with
that research it is possible that there
is a working group it is my ward central
harbour but I know nothing about a
working group but that may be because I
haven't done my homework or read my
emails I would like to know more about
it we need it and I would like to
encourage this chamber to embrace it and
to look at the losses why all those
losses and how can we stop them and how
can we actually reverse the fortunes of
the Fulton Harbor with imagination and
with something with a plan that is
economically viable robust and abundant
thank you Thank You counselor Martin
councillor fella hey Jeff we know but a
working group has been set up which
includes some of the members from
Ramsgate from the debate so far there is
a wish that some independent advice is
brought about to to this debate I was
wondering if a suggestion could be that
this council requests that the working
party that is set up also includes some
independent advisors I think I think the
leaders already indicated that that may
be the case once the working party gets
up and running sorry chair just come
back on that you've just said it it may
include I think that really this council
could actually request that in the terms
of a working party that there are some
advisors I think we can put forward a
suggestion and I think this council can
decide whether that suggestions put
forward I think the nub of the
suggestion has already been discussed
and I'm sure will be taken on ball or
has been taken on board by members of
the working party that are in the
chamber with us this evening so can I
suggest that that is the case and do
members agree in that case as I said
before the petition will go before the
executive committee and obviously the
working party will have input into the
outcome and I'm sure and hope that this
council will be given regular updates on
where we're going how we're going and
some of the work particularly once they
decide on their terms of reference thank
agenda item 7 is questions from the
press and public to questions have been
received from members of the public in
accordance with council procedure rule
13 please note that only the questioner
and the respondent are permitted to
speak on the question and that if the
questioner is not present at this
meeting their question cannot be put but
will be replied to in writing could the
questioner please only state the name of
the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put and read out and
read out the exact sorry can we remove
that sorry can we remove that sorry I'll
start again could the questioner please
only state the name of the cabinet
member to whom their question is to be
put and read out the exact wording of
the question that they submitted to the
council agenda item 7 a question number
1 from a member of the public regarding
River Oaks strategic partnership
DCO application I'm pleased to welcome
mr. green to the meeting could you
please make your way to the top table
it's green
good evening counselor bhava highways
England historic England natural England
public health England Kent County
Council Canterbury City Council many
local groups and 1,100 individual Senate
residents have registered concerns
regarding River Oaks to teach at
partnerships development control order
application could you detail how the the
council has engaged with the applicant
to reduce a statement of common ground
and the local impact report what issues
have been discussed and whether these
have been included in a section 106
agreement Thank You mr. green and I work
on a no small previous councillor I now
call upon the leader to respond thanks
Jim thank for your question mr. green
the council is engaging with the
applicant on the planning matters raised
in our pre application letter and
relevant representation both of which
have been published on the council's
website and on the planning
inspectorate's website these have
discussed how the council and the
applicant can work to resolve as many of
the issues raised in these documents as
possible to inform the council's local
impact report and any statement of
common ground produced there's a
decision for the planning inspector as
the examining authority whether a
section 106 agreement would be required
in addition to a development consent
order if the project is granted Thank
You calcify furred and once again thank
you count mr. green
nearly a Freudian slip there women a
gender item 7b question number two from
the member of the public regarding
Ramsgate port and harbor with members
please refer to supplementary agenda
number one and I'm pleased to welcome
mr. Weis to the meeting could you please
make your way to the top table mr. Weis
the leader Ramsgate port harbor is said
to have lost circa twenty million pounds
since 2010
will you please list the Services
Council jobs and grants through
organizations such as the Citizens
Advice bureaux that have been lost as a
result of the council's failure to
manage this loss making TVC
infrastructure thank you Thank You mr.
Weiss I've called upon the leader to
respond yeah Thank You chairman Thank
You mr. Wallace for your question
Ramsgate Portland Harbor has indeed
operated a net deficit or loss since
2010 as you say in the region of 20
million based on published accounts the
council scrutiny panel was recently
investigated in depth the details behind
many of the items of expenditure that
comprised the port's activities since I
became leader I've made it clear that we
need to address the future of the port
as one of tDCS
major assets the port has suffered
financially as a result of losses from
trans Europa and legal claims related to
live animal exports the entirely
legitimate strategy of this council for
many years has been to maintain the pool
in a state of readiness for an operator
that could generate significant
employment for the council currently we
continue to actively pursue a contract
with a new potential operator and we
hope this will come to fruition but
there will come a time soon when we have
to move to a new strategy for the pool
one way we take action to reduce the
ongoing costs coupled with a fresh look
at long term options other than
continuing to maintain the pool in the
state of readiness for an operator these
are me afraid impossible to answer to
the park the question related to the
services jobs and grants asked that lost
over the last eight years as a result at
the port in Harbor I couldn't possibly
establish causality any more than I
could argue that say job losses are as a
direct result of the reductions in
government funding over the years and
I'm sure as a previous financial
portfolio holder you will understand
that counselor wise thank you Thank You
council papered Thank You counsel mr.
wires keep slipping into that
it's a question of our usual thing
gender I some eight questions from
members of the council no questions have
been received from members in accordance
with council procedure rule 14 agenda
item nine motions of notice no motions
and notice have been received in
accordance with council procedure number
three gender item 10 leaders report I
call upon the leader
thanks Sherman I'm pleased to advise
that we submitted our draft local plan
to the Secretary of State for
Communities and Local Government on the
30th October
this included the draft local plan the
sustainability appraisal and habitats
regulation assessment and statement of
consultation together with the
representations received a publication
stage and the supporting evidence as
well as being available to view online
the documents can also be viewed at the
gateway plus building in Cecil Street in
addition paper copies can be viewed at
various locations across Stanek the
draft Local Plan will be examined in
public by independent inspectors who
have been appointed by the Planning
Inspectorate the council has also
appointed a Program Officer for this
examination part of the process will
involve sessions where those invited to
attend will have the opportunity to
respond to matters raised by the
inspector invitation to participate is
coordinating through the planning
inspector and the program officer always
to stress this both of whom are
independent from fanuc District Council
but we will keep councillors informed
with the dates of these sessions
returning to a familiar thing the port
of Ramsgate has been in national news
news headlines in the last few weeks
this follows reports in Bloomberg and
the Financial Times on Sunday the
central government is preparing to
invest the significant amount of money
in the pool so it can be used as an
alternative route post brexit Planet
Council has been working on
reestablishing ferry services at the
port of Ramsgate and it's currently
still in negotiations with the potential
operator and Seabourn Freight to
establish a freight operation between
Ramsgate and us
and the council has been keen to
reestablish a ferry service since before
the vote to leave the European Union we
recognize that Ramsgate could play a
role in supporting post brexit
resilience by offering an alternative
route for some cross channel traffic to
ensure at least some movement of goods
should there be significant delays in
Dover as part of this the council has
reviewed the capability of the port of
Ramsgate to provide capacity to support
the brexit position which with an
investment of 26 million includes the
potential for up to 24 signings a day
which would create a capacity to devote
to divert 3360 lorry movements per day
from operation Brock on the m20 in m26
significantly reducing pressure from the
Port of Dover and during peak traffic
flows this would be especially
beneficial to the just-in-time
production processes and logistics for
example the chilled food sector this
information has been shared with
government the government has not
responded to the council on that basis
but we are aware the government is
having discussions with other parties
which have regarding contingency
arrangements the port is one of the
largest municipal owned commercial ports
there's a second closest UK port to the
continent the requirement for caution
cross channel freight volume is expected
to increase steadily beyond brexit and
the fault of Ramsgate can play a
significant part in providing additional
capacity this would give increased
resilience to the European logistics
market and support the flow of traffic
across the South East of England
especially the Thames corridor and would
link into they come in third Thames
Crossing diverting traffic East rather
than South to Dover and the Channel
Tunnel changing the subject
I'm pleased to report that the number of
people sleeping on our streets has
reduced by nearly 50% from 45 to 23 over
the past year this was established when
we took part in the annual rough sleeper
count I'm sure that our recently
established rise team will continue this
trend and on a related point this year's
Stanek Winter Shelter has now opened now
in its third year the award-winning
shelter opened its doors to continue its
work of helping people to find
accommodation
so that they don't return to the streets
the shelter is run by the Salvation Army
was support from the council and local
churches this year thanks to additional
counseling funding the shelter is
running for an extra month until the end
of March 2019 the venue of the shelter
moves each night and is also supported
by a number of different churches across
the net as well have provided at least
20 bed spaces every night some venues
have additional empty spaces the shelter
also provides guests with a hot dinner
and breakfast again changing the subject
recently TDC played host to a small
group of visitors from art and North
town Borough Council Northern Ireland
the area includes Banga a seaside town
13 miles east of Belfast they were here
to find out about the council's role in
theory generation in fannia as part of
this they took a tour of Cliftonville
revisited to turn a contemporary in
dream land were hosted over at Royal
Harbor and met the town team in
Broadstairs they were particularly
interested in the turn of contemporary
and the party had played in the cultural
literary generation of Margate this
follows this visit follows those by
Great Yarmouth Borough Council and the
House of Lords Select Committee looking
into regeneration in Seaside towns and
communities who were here to see what
had been achieved in Fannett following
up on the select committee visit TDC
were asked to suggest how government
could help in addressing the challenges
faced by coastal towns we attended a
workshop with representatives from other
seaside areas to explore this further
amongst the ideas put forward were for
funding programs to be less short-term
enabling projected to be supported
longer for seat funding programs to be
established to encourage private sector
investment and for funding programs to
be focused on supporting coastal
communities rather than coastal
destinations ie
for the benefit of residence not
visitors we also took the opportunity to
ask for policy and funding support
linked to the placement of vulnerable
children and adults which as you all
know is a significant issue in Senate
our housing theme has produced the guide
to housing services in Thanet which will
be delivered to every household in the
district distribution of the 16-page
mela which has been produced by an
projects limited at no cost to TDC and
with support from local advertisers
began on the 29th of October it includes
information on all the key services that
the housing theme provides as well as
details on HMO licensing empty
properties and our program of developing
affordable homes most on the subject of
housing it's good to note the TDC has
recently brought another 40 homes back
into use and their empty homes Officer
Tom Davis is one of rising star award
you heard about that earlier I'm pleased
to announce the launch of a digital par
compiler this administration is
committed to keep working towards a
parking offering which makes the
expectations of our residents in terms
of availability ease of use and price
throughout the pilot we're working with
Canterbury City Council who are
presently rolling out digital parking
having already carried out their own
pilots this will enable us to learn from
their experience and hopefully avoid
some of the teething problems the system
uses automatic number plate recognition
technology which will enable us to offer
a number of benefits to users one of the
things residents told us was that they
wanted to pay for exactly the time they
were parked rather than by the hour
which led either to people rushing back
to meet a deadline or paying for time
they didn't use this can be achieved
with a PNR interestingly evidence
suggests that people park and pay for
longer under the new system there will
also be more options for paying payment
can be made by cart Apple pay Android
pay and also pay rather like the dark
charge where people can drive in drive
out the money is automatically taken
from their account and people can also
pay by cash
that's in there for you Casa Campbell in
terms of benefits that accounts for
these include less need for enforcement
in the Canterbury pilot the number of
penalty charged notices went down from
402 for the increased revenue due to
people staying longer improve security
as there's less cash to handle and
better real-time operational data
parking is an ongoing issue which
affects residents visitors and
businesses and proven our offer will
have far-reaching benefits in November I
attended a meeting of the Thames gateway
strategic group which was considering
its response to the Thames Estuary
Commission 2050 vision report which
recommended that a robust locally led
review of governance arrangement be
undertaken it was proposed that at MSS
tree growth and prosperity broad we set
out which would be a single voice for
the Thames Estuary it's believed that
the history needs an ambitious long-term
strategic growth plan together would
jointly agreed investment programme for
key strategic infrastructure it's
further suggested that there needs to be
a structure agreed with government that
can be a single point of coordination
and escalation for strategically
important issues there also needs to be
a clear set of expectations from
government about housing numbers jobs
and economic growth the feeling is that
the Thames Estuary
could become an area whose identity is
as prominent in government thinking as
the northern powerhouse
or the Midlands engine most on the
subjects of growth and infrastructure
I'm pleased to report that the tannic
Parkway project continues to be actively
supported by Kent County Council let's
hope that funding will be secured by
2019 thank you thank you leader kemp
sathya brass are you responding in the
absence that counts the world thank you
thank you
it's very good to hear that there's
almost a 50% reduction of people
sleeping rough on our streets although
it shouldn't make us complacent as there
is such a thin line between those that
are able to retain a roof over their
heads and those that can't for one
reason or another well done to those
that went out and did the headcount I
joined the team last June found it to be
a cold and thought-provoking experience
it's excellent news that we've been able
to find some extra funding to allow the
winter shelter to remain open for longer
this year as I was involved in the setup
of this right from the start I'm
delighted that it's still going
three years later and continuing to help
those in dire need at this time of year
I've seen the council's admission to the
House of Lords Select Committee and I am
disappointed at how Margate centric is
with only a couple of mentions in
passing for Ramsgate in the whole
document Ramsgate is also entirely
different and we must remember that
Fanny is much bigger than just Margate
like to say an additional well done to
Tom Davis for his rising star award and
hope that we will continue bringing
empty properties back into use well into
the future thank you
Thank You councillor brass I don't think
there's a need to respond there was no
questions there yep counts of a third of
course Ramsgate hasn't been forgotten
no of all the other places in Fannett
thank you he didn't mention the B word
did he councillor Piper can I called
can I call upon council Reverend Piper
to comment on or ask questions in
relationship to the leaders report
counts the piper Thank You mr. chairman
I must try and stick to the script the
local plan leader it is of some relief
to many people I'm sure that the Local
Plan process is moving along I have been
accused by some of grandstanding and
playing politics in this chamber and
naturally enough I strongly reject these
claims however this is an opportunity
that is simply too good to miss so here
goes with the playing politics on this
issue of the local plan I speak for my
whole group when I say that we are proud
of the fact that the decisive action we
took in January of this year has managed
in some way to unblock the logjam which
was a long overdue local plan submission
end of politics we recognize that an
extraordinary amount of work has been
done by officers and their staff to
fulfill our council obligations in that
regard
many might argue that it isn't perfect
but to be fair
very few plans in any walk of life are
perfect but somehow they sometimes seem
to work we are at least leader in the
game now and for the time being we
remain in control of our own affairs the
port and harbor leader as you say the
port has been in the news for many of
the wrong reasons of late and perhaps it
is time for a somewhat better outlook
there is however a report apparently
coming from Belgium that things may not
be as far advanced as we're being
reported on this side of the water but
ever the optimists we await further news
of a successful development of Ramsgate
port which is has been said a
substantial asset in Ramsgate and trust
that whatever route is taken it will be
taken for the genuine benefit of the
people of Thanet and will provide jobs
and economic benefits to local people
the winter shelter leader I think it's
right and proper for councillor Jenni
matter face and councils in Bravos
Fairbrass to make the majority of the
comments on this subject it's an area
which they have a great deal more
knowledge than most but may I just offer
thanks to all those involved in this
great service the housing team there are
areas where this council demonstrates
excellence in service and the housing
team are regularly recognized for their
efforts and any plaudits are richly
deserved the digital parking pilot
scheme well we shall look forward to an
update on the success of that pilot
scheme here in thinik the Thames gateway
strategic group meeting it will be
interesting to see when in fact the
government does come up with a realistic
assessment of current and future housing
needs jobs and economic growth
but may I ask you to use all your
influence to ensure that whatever they
do can they please not involve Mark
Carney in their predictions zanuck
Parkway in my personal view leader for
Thanet to prosper
Vanek Parkway must be a part of the
bigger picture for our future
development and growth strategy not in
your report leader zanuck independent
counselors would like to wish every
Senate resident a Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year we would have liked to
include the word prosperous however that
word seems to have become somewhat
redundant possibly replaced by austerity
Thank You mr. chairman but could I just
ask mr. chairman I didn't actually get
an answer to my earlier question whether
we are now free to correspond with mr.
Cootes that wasn't an appropriate
question and I can't answer it leader
would you like to respond yes thank you
chairman I didn't think that was too
political counts the pythor and I think
most of your comments I would echo I was
remiss of me actually not not to wish
everybody members offices residents of
planet alike a very Merry Christmas and
I think I do that to almost everybody in
sani thank you
Thank You council about a face would you
like to respond hoping I'm one of the
ones going to be wish'd Merry Christmas
as the last person to respond to the
leaders report I assumed others would
pick up on some of the issues already
and indeed they have so I want to
highlight the amazing work done by our
rise team their officers the housing
officers the Salvation Army and the many
volunteers and supporting the winter
shelter as councillor Piper mentioned
obviously I have some experience there
we shouldn't also forget the work done
by many counselors in preventing
residents from becoming homeless because
we're able to liaise with agencies and
offices and I actually spent Tuesday
morning
my very best to deal with a housing
association and getting very little
support but thanks to some officers here
that situation has been dealt with I
would like to ask however how many empty
properties are currently known I know
you've referenced them but how many are
currently known to JDC and how many
could be used even temporarily to house
families rather than be sent out of area
as we know many do get sent well away
which causes problems with employment
and obviously with schooling what more
could be done to bring them back into
use that's a question I will address
which I'm assuming cancel the game will
be able to deal with having already been
able to do some sessions at the Winter
Shelter because it opened earlier I
would like to draw everyone's attention
to some the four main issues as I see
them firstly the lack of affordable
housing mainly one-bedroom flats we need
to get building more suitable properties
and we definitely need at some point a
hostel that is open all year staffed
with experts to help rough sleepers keep
off the streets secondly the constant
rise in rents not matched by rising
wages we need our economy to grow much
faster locally with sustainable
employment the ports already been
mentioned several times so I would like
to ask counsel of a friend how are you
going to guarantee secure local
employment for people with if and when
the port is actually back open full-time
thirdly the lack of mental health and
rehab facilities needed to help those
locally rather than be sent miles away
from family and friends my observation
last evening at salutes in Ramsgate was
out of the 12 ross sleepers house
they're far too many had serious mental
health issues and we didn't have last
evening as we did have two years ago
psychiatric nurse available for them to
talk to we had to call the police in the
end because there was a situation that
could have got out of hand
fourthly and from my own perspective and
I know my cut many of my colleagues the
impact Universal Credit has had on those
whose housing benefit is delayed
sometimes its delay
by months and in fact I met one
gentleman in the housing shell in the
Winter Shelter who had been evicted due
to a two and a half month delay on
housing benefit we need to put pressure
in my opinion and my colleagues would
agree on the government to remove
housing benefit from being one of the
six benefits rolled into universal
credit all of those and some individual
situations mean that this evening across
Cecil Square in the Baptist Church hole
20 homeless people both men and women of
all ages are settling down for the night
and I consider this is unacceptable as a
matter face I don't believe that was
covered by the leaders report and I mean
worthy as it is I think if you can sum
up we've had questions and I'll see if
the leader or the portfolio holder can
respond in any way but if you can sum up
I'm referencing my experiences from
volunteering at the Winter Shelter and I
consider there were valid points but
finally I would like to ask counselor
Beaufort if we could have an update on
the East Kent housing situation as I'm
aware some issues were raised last week
at the housing coffee evening perhaps
you could arrange that
please thank you Thank You councillor
metaphase and can I personally thank
those councils that are involved with
the rough sleeping exercise currently
Thank You councillor Beaufort
yeah Thank You chairman I mean you asked
a lot of questions there I don't have
the answer so I'll come back to you and
I yeah that would be brilliant yeah and
well done for sneaking a lot of
political comments past our Chairman's
evening Thank You general item 11 is a
report of the chairman of the executive
policy and Community Safety scrutiny
panel
I call upon council a Glenn Coleman cook
to be sent his report mr. Coleman called
Thank You mr. chair the executive
scrutiny panel met on the 13th of
November to review its work program
which include a consideration of the
report on crime statistics in Spanish
which was presented by
and police they spoke about the
initiatives they taken working in
collaboration with other agencies to
reduce crime particularly with regards
to anti-social behaviour in the district
the panel was also consulted on the
housing allocations policy as part of
the public consultation on new proposals
although members of knowledge the
proposals looked appropriate they
recommended that the key worker list
should include care support workers
which will be considered by cabinets on
the 15th of January the pan also
included an individual cabinet member
called in on digital parking pilot
project members felt that the
information provided in the report
accompanying the decision could have
been more detailed the leader of the
council standing in for the portfolio
holder acknowledged this points and
indicated that the issue had since been
resolved as the portfolio holder was
given a briefing the offices during
discussion additional information was
also provides to the panel and
thereafter no further action was taken
members further reviewed the food loss
service plan and enforcement policy
report while recommending the policy for
adoption by council the plan also
proposed that the cabinet's should
identify funding for staff training and
additional staffing in order to
effectively deliver the highly needed
statutory service and this item is
reported on under agenda item 40 I'd
like to invite members to comment on and
report Thank You councillor Johnson and
council constant time thank you very
much thank you
councillor Coleman cook it's four point
one about the museums report and it's
something I've asked about before the
fifty thousand pounds left by Joyce and
lady lovely lady to the Dickens House
Museum have you had a response from
cabinet on the an up-to-date situation
there because this money I think was
bequeathed in about 2014-2015 and under
4.1 you're asking whether it could be
used for the maintenance of the museum
and the other question was whether TDC
had the right to dispose of the building
did you get an answer from cabinet Thank
You council kolonko do you Kevin Johnson
I don't believe we have any response yet
but I will look into their negative
council Constantine thank you very much
thank you for your report to have
couple of questions which you may or may
not be able to help me with but I think
they're important to raising it in the
chamber one is to do with the crime
statistics on rape and sexual assault
some while ago something was described
as the sex crimes capital of Kent the
reason it's described as such is because
3.5 that the the rate for offense in
this part of the world is 3.58 per 1000
of head of population compared to the
national average of 2.5 2.5 3 which is
the national average per head of 1000 so
I wanted to know if any actions being
taken on but in that particular area
what are we doing about that are there
any plans is it on anybody's agenda and
then my other point was and I appreciate
you may not have the answers we've we
continue to be an outlier in terms of
domestic violence against women and I
wonder what steps were being taken
because again we were outside of the
national average and I just wondered if
this was something you could give me
some feedback on thank you are you able
to respond to council : I don't recall
you presented but if you can take on
board the comments and perhaps consider
them if they're not in the report this
evening you can consider with your
committee and a future meeting thank you
absolutely Thank You members general
item 12 reported the chairman of the
finance budget and performance scrutiny
panel
I call upon council in the piper Thank
You chair the panel have met twice since
for the full council meeting in October
one of the key items on the agenda for
the 23rd of October panel meeting was
the presentation on the performance of
the Ramsgate port and harbor by the
leader of the council a number of
questions were forwarded to the leader
of the council as part of the
preparation for the meeting and these
were responded to as part of the
presentation by the leader members have
the opportunity to ask additional
supplementary questions during the
discussion and these were individually
responded to by the leader
it was further agreed that the port and
harbor talk topic would be added to
items for a future members briefing
session the panel also considered
proposals for the 2019 stroke 20 counsel
fees and charges at the meeting on the
20th of November and forward did the
recommendations to cabinet as detailed
in my report these proposals were
considered by cabinet today and were to
be brought before this council meeting I
would like to invite members to comment
and thereafter note the report
additionally I'd like to thank mr. Nick
Hughes and the Charles Hanway for all
the administration all the
administrative work they do on behalf of
this committee thank you
Thank You councillor Piper a tender item
thirteen 2019-20 fees and charges I
would advise that in accordance with
council procedure rule seventeen point
six I will call for a recorded vote on
the motion or any amendments and
substantive motions
I call upon councillor Gregory Thank You
chair the proposed fees and charges were
considered and approved by cabinet on
the 15th of November and followed by the
finance budget performance scrutiny
panel and the 20th of November the
scrutiny panel made four of
recommendations to cabinet and an
extraordinary meeting this afternoon
cabinet considered those those four
recommendations that I'm reporting on
that now verbally because obviously
there hasn't been time for it to be
printed up and taking them in turn the
first recommendation was to consider
removing the fee for cremation services
of children and it says in the report
under the age of 7 years however we
don't have a fee for children under
seven years we have a chewer fee for up
to 12 years and a fee for 12 to 17 years
so we consider that was probably an
error and it's probably was misheard and
reporting that so we have actually
cabins considered this and we've decided
that we will actually
increase the age for for free cremations
if I can put it that way up to 17 years
of age so no no young persons under the
age of 17 years of age will pay anything
infinite for cremations now which we
think will be you know well liked by
people in unfortunate circumstances the
second recommendation was to review the
cost for cremation services for all age
groups having considered similar charges
in other districts officers have
undertaken a benchmarking exercise and
have told us that we are competitive
with other crematoria in the area in the
in the area of Kent and I have to say
that at the scrutiny panel meeting a
good piece of work done by the
councillor reverend piper was to provide
us with some figures and passed out to
the committee members on other criminal
in the area and i'll tell you what they
were it was vintners crematories 807
pounds from the age of 15 Bluebell Hill
was 840 pounds from the age of 16 TDC
will be 876 pounds now from the age of
17
Barham was 895 from the age 16 and
Hawkins was 999 from age 17 now the last
to do actually include some option of
what we consider an option optional
extras such as music and and the
collection and distribution of hashes so
if you'll see from that though thank you
very much councillor Piper that term
that we we sit quite well within the
comparison with the other crematoria in
Kent so cancer so cabinet decided not to
do anything as far as that no change to
that to the fees there the third
recommendation was to review the
licensing fee changes in order to
determine whether it was appropriate
that no increases in licensing fees were
proposed for this year officers again
report back to us and said that you know
these are obviously regulated charges we
are not
allowed to charge more than the service
cost us to provide and comparisons be
made and found that in fact there is no
justification in increasing the charges
this year because it's not costing the
council any more to provide that service
so no changes there and the fourth
recommendation was to consider whether
is appropriate to set up an all-party
cabinet advisory group to look at future
fees and charges and we think that's a
great idea because you know there are
lots of questions to be asked about
parking and various other things in fees
and charges and we get to this time of
the year and really it's all it's all
been presented to us and we would like
to have more involvement in asking those
questions earlier on so yes we would
like to set up for the for the next year
a cabinet advisory group to look at
future fees and charges there are the
four recommendations so I would like to
propose that Council approves the fees
and charges for 2019 including the two
recommendations accepted by cabinet
second thank you
can I have a second ax comes up a third
counsel constant time was first lien
councillor Johnson you may recall in
December 2016 a motion was put to
central government to find a fund for
ten million pounds to fund the deaths of
children and that motion fell you may
recall I think we brought that to this
chamber to say was there something that
tannic District Council could do I'm
very glad that we can you know relieve
parents and carers of the burden of
paying for a cremation at that time I do
wonder if we could go further and there
are I do wonder if we could go further
and I wonder if we could fund other
types of funerals for children I think
that's one of the reasons we're looking
to have a working party to look at all
aspects and see how far we can go within
our budget requirements counselor
thank you very much chairman Thank You
councillor Gregory my concern is the
charge is the increase of 20% on the
coach parking tourism is obviously a
major industry for us here and it's
always been a difficult one we did have
a coach park in cliftonville that we got
funding for in which we subsidized
ourselves but this is going to be a
massive increase people who come on
holiday here by coach sorry people who
come here by coach always have a problem
financially at the best of times and
knowing from my stint as chair of
British destinations it was often an
issue that Coach company is raised with
us it looks from the paperwork here on
page 49 that it is an increase of 20%
did you discuss all of this with hotel
ears and other traders in the industry
council correctly are you able to
respond yes Thank You councillor Johnson
no I don't know the answer to that
whether it's been discussed with
hoteliers in the area I would imagine
that as with most of our parking fees
that they are they have been benched
marked with other areas and that's the
reason why it's been put up to that but
I'll certainly find out and give you a
fuller explanation
thank you councillor Constantine you've
had one bite of the cherry are there any
other councillors wish to make comment
before I go to the recorded vote
council in the piper Thank You chair I
just like to thank councillor Gregory
and his team and the cabinet for
considering our recommendations and
acting positively towards them thank you
very much thank you
I'll now instruct the monitoring officer
to conduct the recorded vote
Thank You chairman councillor Ashby
that's AB a furred Council brim Casa
Buckley Casa Campbell calcic Glenn
Coleman cook Casa Keith Coleman cook
Casa Constantin casa crow Brown
councillor Dawson
caocao de casa della Casa dexter causa
edwards castle jeremy Fairbrass castle
in Fairbrass casa Falcon Gaza Fenner
castle game counselor Gregory Casa Grove
Plaza hatin oh yeah Casa Hillman castor
Jay Jones Casa Johnston Casa Larkin's
Catherine Martin castle a matter face
counselor Parsons counselor Linda Piper
counselor Reverend Stewart Piper
Katherine counselor Linda Potts
counselor Roy Potts
no yeah Castle up you
that's a Rogers Clausura Zeki castle Oh
David Saunders counselor may eve
saunders Cather savage customers
purchasing Keller Taylor counselor
Taylor Smith Casa Tomlinson counselor
Townend
casa right thank you thank you
that's cut that's carried agenda item 14
food law service plan and enforcement
policy 2018 to 2020
I call upon council game
okay the Food Standards Agency required
local authorities to produce a plan that
outlines how we provide our food safety
service this food law enforcement plan
and policy sets out how the public
protection team will prioritize and
manage their work for the next 24 months
taking into account the unknown elements
of brexit and the Food Standards Agency
reform known as regulating our future
the impacts on service delivery from
these two things are unknown and this is
reflected in this document which is why
it is a hefty but necessary read I hope
you've all read it is the annex attached
to agenda number 14 the Public
Protection team have been keeping track
of these changes and continue to do so
adjusting service delivery where
necessary
they have also along with the Kent food
group made representative
representations about the likely impact
of proposals on small local businesses
the plan also takes into account the
functions that the team currently
perform by carrying out programmed
inspections of 1359 food premises
according to the food law code of
practice as well as health and safety
duties whelk traceability events work
routines on sampling Street auditing
complaints caravan parks and infectious
disease work the plan has been presented
to the executive scrutiny panel and
cabinet where members were supportive of
the work the team undertake I would
therefore like to propose that council
approved the food loss service plan
thank you thank you can also gain do I
have a seconder councillor second hm
thank you do members agree thank you a
general item 15 changes to committees
panels and boards 2008
19 would members please refer to
supplementary agenda number one
proportionality I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect of the
options as outlined in the report causa
baitha Thank You chairman Lee if that's
just the labor group this effect I
believe option one was your no number
two okay offers option to their chairman
does does any member wish to propose an
alternative option in that case do
members agree thank you nomination to
members to serve on committees group
leaders may wish to make take this
opportunity to advise of changes to
their nominations to committees panels
and books for the remainder of the
2018-19 period council paper do you wish
to advise of any nomination changes
council Fairbrass council cannon ball
yeah just sorry chair just so a couple
of meetings ago I did suggest that
members of its external committees could
use the facilities of the loop magazine
to actually report back from those
committees to members to inform the
water he doesn't seem that anybody has
actually taken up that particular
wonderful suggestion I thought however
those you don't think it was wonderful
is wonderful and we bothered by yeah I
just hope to yoga remind those who are
are on these external committees we
don't want you to bring voluminous
reports to this particular council but
we would like you to include them in the
loop that goes around to members so that
info information could be gathered from
those external committees thank you Jeff
thank you thank you Kelso Reverend Piper
do you wish to make any changes to
nominations no chairman thank you thank
you very much
Thank You members that now concludes the
business of the meeting this evening
oh sorry kept counselor matter face
sorry
as we're losing the seat on the boundary
electoral working party obviously that
doesn't mean and we've lost at sea so
I'm not making a changes to any of the
others they are as they were before
thank you very much thank you can I just
say that we've now concluded the
business I will let Tara John speak but
for those members that are not joining
us on the first floor can I wish members
happy Christmas and a particularly
healthy New Year councillor Johnson
quickly German I'd like to wish you a
very happy Christmas and a very
prosperous new year hopefully and I'd
also like to thank you this evening
because I didn't have to wave
frantically I didn't have to get upset
and actually I noticed that you did
actually pay considerable attention to
us women this evening it was a
refreshing change thank you Thank You
Council on some those who know me know
that I know my place